hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the MR dodgy
Invitational this is from the
semi-finals and it is Samuel Savion
versus Magnus Carlson and in the other
part of the semi-finals is of course
Daniel dubov versus uh Alexander grishuk
and this is one of the games that I
thought was really awesome as it
features one uh truly wonderful move
that I decided to use as the pause the
video moment uh here Samuel Simeon has
the white pieces and he opens with E4
Magnus replies with Pawn to E5 we have
Knight F3 Knight to C6 and now at Bishop
to C4 we have Knight to F6 and now I
know everyone is sad when people don't
play nice the G5 here but as usual we
have D3 the so-called modern Bishop's
opening Bishop to E7 and both players
Castle so this is all very standard
stuff we have knighted the C3 D6 and now
Pawn to eighth removing all the side
pawns with h6h3 and now you can also
play A5 but here we have Rook to E8 by
Magnus Rook day one 1 and the best of
the f8 this is all again all very
standard stuff the bishop will help out
with the defense of the king and the
Rook Now controls the center and there
is one game where Pawn to B4 was played
and of course you guys can understand
that but here we have D4 by Samuel and
it is not as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game and you should
capture this uh you know by all means if
captures captures you play D5 and you
are very happy with black here let's say
Knight captures B captures the bishop is
hanging Bishop to F1 and now black has a
variety of choices here you could
Advance the a pawn you could push the
d-pawn you could capture it all depends
on what kind of a game you want to play
you could play Rook to B8 put pressure
on this hinder the development of the
dark Square bishop and so on but Magnus
decides to go for Bishop to D7 he
doesn't want to ruin the the central
tension just yet Bishop to E3 and only
now captures on D4 why did he include
Bishop to D7 of course only he knows as
he is the world champion Knight captures
on D4 we have Knight to the E5 now
attacking the bishop and Bishop to Aid
you also you could maybe shift it over
T2 or or F1 but this also makes sense as
it controls this wonderful diagonal we
have C6 by Magnus and pawn to F4 now
Knight the G6 and now Queen to D3
and queen to D3 is basically setting up
the advancement of the E Pawn as the F
Pawn is pinned that means that the
Knight isn't really defended so if you
push the pawn queen captures on G6
becomes a real possibility and that's
exactly what we'll see Magnus plays
Queen to A5 and now although objectively
you should continue with something
developing like rogator D1 or Shifting
the knights but here we have Pawn to E5
this is a Blitz game five plus so so of
course it moves like E5 are more than
welcome the characters on E5 uh and then
now Pawn to B4 first chasing away the
black queen queen back to d8 this is
pretty much the only good Square for the
black queen maybe C7 but okay Queen 38
and now Queen captures and G6 this is of
course impossible due to the bishop and
the bishop captures an F7 check is
coming or even Queen captures an F7 uh
but uh it's merely an illusion uh which
Magnus Falls for here you should play e
captures on D4 and this isn't really an
option because if you go for Bishop
captures on F7 check King h8 there's
just no time to go after the Rook if you
capture the Rogue Bishop capture 78
attacks the White Queen and now after we
move the queen you also pick up the
bishop here and after Rook captures uh
black has two Bishops for a rook of
course black is completely winning here
uh so a bit of a trick there on Magnus
okay Magnus goes at night to D5 and then
now we have Bishop characters on D5 now
you have to do something because this is
now a threat there is no longer the
pinning of the F7 Pawn so Bishop
captures on D5 with C captures on D5 and
now Queen back to G3 e captures on D4
Magnus now finally grabs that piece
Bishop captures on D4 and now Rook
captures an E1 Rook captures in the
bishop to F5 now you can see how that
Bishop to f8 move really comes in handy
as it prevents white from delivering
Checkmate on G7 uh and now okay Bishop
to F5 stopping the advancement of the F1
also the bishop will help out with the
defense of the black king also the C2
Pawn is hanging and Samuel goes for Rook
to E5 attacking the bishop and the D5
pawn and okay Magnus grabs the C2 Pawn
Rook captures on D5 we have Queen to E8
and now Rook back to E5 we have Queen to
D7 and now it seems like you could
continue just chasing the black queen
but not really after Rook D5 Queen E6
and rookie 5 you're gonna see Queen to
B3 and uh well the A3 Pawn is now
hanging uh it's not not the best for
white uh so instead Knight to D5 Samuel
goes for an all-out attack and it's very
very dangerous the uh the Knight to F6
check will be deadly here
uh if you if you play something weird uh
let's say you play something like a rook
to d8 Knight to F6 check and black
resigns as you lose the Queen the g-pawn
is pinned uh you you've just lost your
queen so Magnus has to run with the king
king GH [ __ ] or King to H7 he chooses
the H7 square and now Queen to F2 uh by
Samuel Magnus brings The Rook into the
game and uh Samuel says all right we're
gonna grab a pawn while we're at it
whether it's a good or not it is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
but for a five minute Blitz game maybe
maybe focusing on the attack was the way
to go it's hard to say we have Bishop to
B3 by Magnus and now Knight to E3 the
Knight will now shift uh to the attack
via the king side uh F6 attacking the
rook and now Rook to H5 and although
this seems like a really really awesome
attacking Outpost it's actually a tomb
uh for for this for this Rook uh which
you will see uh Queen to D3 by Magnus
and now with Queen to D3 he's preparing
Rook to see E3 is preparing Rook to C1
checking H2 Bishop to D6 all sorts of
ideas now become possible and it's hard
to meet all of them but what you can do
is play Bishop to C5 to at least prevent
The Rook from delivering check on C1 but
now you guys will see what I meant by
what I've said uh feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only actual
winning move for Magnus well I'll give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh well getting
the hint and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is the best
shop to F7 that's the good stuff and now
the Rook is out of squares you can see
that the bishop covers D5 and H5 Pawn
covers E5 and G5 and of course you have
the F5 square and the H4 Square F5
square is a bit more safe if you go Rook
the five then okay Bishop E6 rule goes
back in F5 and it completely cuts off
the white Rook from the game let's say
Bishop captures Rook captures and the
white is basically playing a rook down
uh there's no good way to uh for it to
re-enter the game you can't go to G4 you
can't go to G5 you can't really attack
with it it's just I mean you're down to
look here so Samuel tried Rook the H4
but this is where Magnus is really real
idea yeah it comes to fruition and that
of course is Rook captures on C5 look at
this beautiful move uh and of course it
was in this position on move 32 that
Samuel Savion resigned at the game game
as there is nothing more to be done here
point is if you recapture Bishop
captures on C5 and you cannot defend the
Knight and look at this Knight queen
king on the same diagonal this is a
disaster
uh so yeah Magnus wins this game and he
won pretty much all the other games
against Samuel he uh I believe two games
were drawn the final score was like
seven to one or something like that but
yeah a very very impressive stuff by
Magnus and he will face the winner of
the clash between Daniel Lube of uh and
Alexander grishop and of course the
winner was Daniel dubov truly a
spectacular match also uh so looking
forward
for the finals today and yeah Magnus had
a really really incredible run to the
finals I mean he he really cruised
through the the preliminaries then uh he
uh he he crushed Salah Salim without
losing a single game uh I mean absolute
Annihilation 7-0 I believe the the final
result was then kilo shivchenko okay he
put up a bit of a fight I think a kid
will won three games uh and then Magnus
won the match and now again Samuel
Savion without losing a single game
we'll see what happens in the final as
we have not seen do both in action for
quite a while uh so I'm I'm going to
cover as many games as possible from the
finals yeah like and sorry for not
showing so many games for the past few
days I really had uh some issues with my
with my throat um couldn't really speak
like I said it was more of a squeaking
than speaking uh so I had had to play it
safe uh but yeah I I'm hoping to cover
the finals um as much as I can so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank Jerry driver
aboard A Smith Union Stefan trifonovich
and Andre charade for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day